in the past few minutes manchester city
have won the premier league title as
burnley are relegated let's uh bring in
our sports presenter selena hinchcliffe
straight away
how dramatic i said about my nails you
know if i could bite them anymore they'd
be off by now but it really was touching
go into those final few seconds and not
just at the top at the bottom fourth
place all to play for on the final day
of the season that's right nick so much
at stake manchester city crown champions
their fourth title in five seasons but
it looked at one point that perhaps if
liverpool scored they could snatch it
from city's grasp but they held on and
such dominance from city really when you
think an era now that's
such success from guardiola feats
achieved just by sir alex ferguson at
manchester united he really is cementing
his name in the premier league as you
mentioned burnley relegated they lost
2-1 to newcastle so leeds stay up they
were 2-1 winners over brentford and that
champions league place that looked
nailed on for tottenham but as we know
spurs can always uh
squander things when it gets tight but
they were five nil winners uh over
norwich who'd already been relegated so
they win that champions league spot from
arsenal but yes a very dramatic day
indeed